hello everyone so I'm Jana this is my
colleague Katarina we are really happy
to be here I will start with an
introduction so we work for generally an
insurance company in Milan we work for
the head office for a team called
analytic solution center so our role is
to help generally business units and the
countries to implement analytics and
machine learning into their everyday
work today we will speak about a
particular use case which has to do with
fraud detection so one of the business
unit asked us to help them to find fraud
from images in particular fraud
investigators discovered that there are
cases when people are claiming the same
damage twice so let's head let's say
they have a damage on their car they go
they claim they get the money and then
in a few months or even a year
they have another damage but they didn't
fix the previous one so they ask again
for the money of the previous damage now
of course you could ask why don't people
just check the photos from the previous
claim the problem is that sometimes in
one claim there can be 90 photos so you
have to look 90 by 90 to find if a
scratch is the same so let's start with
a game kind of a game okay so I guess
you all know Spongebob and I guess you
all played at one point to the game
called spot the difference so how many
differences where can you see in this
picture okay I'll help you but every
time I touch it there are actually three
so yes it takes a bit of time actually
to see this so imagine for our claim and
fraud investigators like I said it's not
an easy task when they have to do this
for tens of claims a day ok let's move
to more serious stuff what about in
motor claims can you see the difference
here I mean here there are many but
since I already gave you a hint what
we're looking for you can see that the
damage is different right but everything
else is quite similar so I mean the car
has the same colour is the same brand
the picture is taken from the same angle
the pavement is the same so you can
imagine if you input this if you extract
features from this using some kind of
neural network and then you calculate
some kind of cosine similarity I tell
you that these two pictures are gonna
have a very high similarity so doing
this you're not gonna be able to
understand that there's a different
damage so we need to find a way to make
the model focus on the damage and we
started doing that without doing any
kind of object detection or damage
detection so just from the main picture
let's say so yes like I said damage is
different same example here here I would
say it's easier for human eye to see
that it's different but still for the
computer when we calculate features and
similarity these two are quite quite
similar so basically we don't want to
send to our fraud investigators such
pictures because I don't want to see
this they want to see the same damage
so yes damaged like I said here is on a
different part ok so just a recap what
is our goal we want to help fraud
investigators focus on cases where the
client claimed for the same damage twice
so basically they want a system
the input and image of the damage and
they can get ranking with the most
similar pictures from the history that
have the same damage we have to follow
some steps to do that of course so first
we did some data cleaning feature
extraction and then we started focusing
on a particular model called deep
ranking this model takes a particular
type of input call triplet
Katarina will discuss more about the
model the three plates and how they work
I will start with data cleaning so the
when we got the data we were very
excited finally we have the data let's
start playing with it and doing cool
stuff we got it and we saw that actually
there's a lot of noise like we expected
to see many pictures of damages but
actually there were pictures of
everything so of course there are
pictures of the entire car taking from
far away but those are not very helpful
because we cannot see the damage always
there are pictures of the interior there
is this device that they use to measure
the thickness of the paint and that was
almost in every claim there are pictures
of wheels VIN numbers play numbers but
also spare parts and things like the
place of the accident I remember we saw
some pictures of shops like shops that
have nothing to do with cars of his or
insurance and we were wondering why are
they there and they're like yeah you
know that's the place of the accident we
just put everything there in the
database so basically we have to find a
way to get rid of all these pictures and
just focus on the one with the damage
yes so how did we do this we had to form
some categories some clusters and then
run a classification model we formed
eight categories that you can see here
and we started like most people in
computer vision which with the models
from imagenet so we chose exception we
use transfer learning so we froze the
first layers of exception until the
layer where features are extracted then
we deleted the last layer that were used
for classification for other tasks and
we replaced with the type of
classification that we were interested
in we did this three times first we
separated and we formed eight categories
the ones I showed you earlier from those
we focused on the pictures of the damage
then we ran another classification model
using again exception and from the
pictures with the damage we were able to
separate them in three categories front
side and back after discussing with the
business they told us that for them the
most interesting ones are the front or
like we can start with the front because
most damages are at the front but anyway
everything we're gonna talk about later
can be adapted to side or back so from
this part we took the images of the
front and then we ran a third
classification model to separate in zoom
damage and not zoom damage of the front
and we focused on zoomed once we did
that we ran the deep ranking model we
did everything after but then we
realized well actually there maybe there
is a better way we can do a multi
labeling so instead of having just
information such as its damaged front
zoom you can have more information like
in this picture there is the grille of
the car or there is the headlight and
the hood or there's a wheel and a
headlight and the hood and this can help
us to form or clusters that are more
useful for our main task again we use we
did this using exception
based model we extracted features using
exception and we added a few more layers
in order to classify in 17 categories we
noticed that people usually in business
like to see some kind of visual example
so rather than just saying yeah you know
we run this and the results are this I'm
telling you our code gave these results
we managed to create this app where you
can input a picture live and there is
it's gonna show you what parts of the
car are in the picture so like here it's
99% swear it's a car 99% sure its side
89% sure its handle 58
it's a rearview mirror and 26% it's a
wheel okay so now Katerina we'll talk
more about the main model and how we
prepared it okay
so once we got the front zoom the images
and the ones we wanted to focus on for
the purpose of the deep ranking model we
had to create something which is called
triplets so the query image in the
triplet represents the image against
which you want to compare the similarity
of the other images then you have
something which we call the positive
which is image which in our case
represents the same damage and this is
the scratch down on the car and the
negative image which represents the very
similar car but this time with a
different damage and this is actually
the fine grain which we want to achieve
with later training the model so we had
to face a problem and it's that we
didn't have a label data so we had in
the history two examples of fraud of
this type why because for a human eye
said it's very hard to do something like
this so we decided to create kind of a
fake set of triplets so the Quarian
positive pair were generated from the
damages from the claims which had more
than one front zoomed image of the same
damage and then the negative was another
car and another claim with a different
image but with still similar
characteristics and the picture which
had very good cosine similarity on
exception features so something which
could be confused with the baseline
which was in our case the exception
features model and once we got to have
the triplets the task was to put them
through a model which can better
differentiate between what is the
positive and what is the negative for
the given query so the model is
published in the paper which is called
learning fine grace image similarity VD
pranking published by some researchers
and mostly people from Google and we
decided to implement it so we have
replaced the Bayes model in the upper
part which you can see in the Green
Square as a ComNet so from Alex net we
moved to exception because we liked it
and we followed the visual inspection
that we had in the previous examples and
this part the upper part of the network
is basically managing to capture the
invariant things so the image semantics
how the total image looks like and in
addition to this as after concatenated
in the ambling part are the two smaller
networks very shallow ones as opposed to
exception which are taking the down
sampled images and trying to capture
some other visual features which are
more prone to
variance and as the result of the
network we get the embeddings so just to
make sure we understood all the three
images are fed independently into this
identical network and then what we do is
basically focus on OS function so loss
function is customized and it is made in
a way to decrease the loss so the
distance in our case between the
beddings of query between the invading
aquarium positive images and Quarian
negative one with the regularization
parameter inside as well so at that
point what we were doing is training and
training and training this model and it
was good because we could see that the
loss was decreasing but after fifty a
box for example we could notice that I
although results were fine the loss was
still decreasing so there was a space to
push this further so what did we do we
use Azure platform so we decided to use
this functionality which is called badge
AI and a sure patch and the run jobs on
cluster of GPUs and non GPUs so GPUs the
for the training of the model and non
repute asks such as the features
extraction for the exception for example
which was good because then the clusters
are running only when your mother is
training and then after that they're
shut down so if you're interested like
in a week of intensive hacking go
training this model you can spend like
20 euros on angel for doing this with
around fifty thousand triplets and one
other thing which we engineered from
original implementation of the pranking
on hit hub is that we created something
which we call super optimized image
generator which basically tries to
prevent tries to decrease
time on images by using the pairs and
with the positive quadrant positive
image and calculating the multiple
negative photos so this is something we
could play with so because we took a
pair and then we generated a couple of
negative photos and in that case if you
do it for like 12 times then you can
change the structure of the image
generator so that you feed the aquarium
positive only once and then you have in
the end 12 different triplets so the
time which you can see is in hours and
it's for 100 a box run and we have
tested this with the exception inside
the upper part of the deep ranking with
frozen layers or with no weights so no
weights is quite huge it's very hard to
fit in memory and these were basic let's
say obstacles that we had so the results
that we cut our pictures like this this
couple and in this picture we could see
that one damage comes from July and the
other from November but it's actually
the same scratch and yes spoiler alert
so it was one of the frauds given to us
in the beginning as an example that this
can happen apart from this we managed to
find some other examples where you can
see that the car is like washed and
there is some Sun on the photo but
otherwise is the same damage and we were
happy but there's always room for some
improvement so what we decided to do is
that from something which is result of
the first trainings and visually
inspected by some investigators we
decided to fill it back to the pranking
but this time taking the true query and
positive and not as in the beginning
from the same claim so we want to let's
say enhance the performance because they
may be the context is different or
something also that we didn't focus on
with fake couples
and another thing that we are working on
is to move from our labeling as a
classification to the segmentation so to
make sure that we are always checking
just the valid parts of the car which
can be further let's say pushed with
this use case and compared against all
the cars but then it would have like
exploding a number of images so we want
to focus only on the ones which contain
the same clusters of the car elements on
it and another thing that we would we
are working on is object detection with
masks are CNN so this is trained on very
limited amount on photos and so what we
noticed is that this can be really
enhanced but the damage itself is not an
object such as cat or dog which you can
find in a cocoa data set or any other
for the object detection so we are
defining the categories of damage if I
can say like this for example scratch
doesn't look the same as the broken
glass or something else like a bomb or
so and the plan is to work further on
this once we generate the labelled data
set so thank you very much
[Applause]
okay questions I have a question so how
big was the test dataset on which you
had the occasion to test your like model
and the other thing is whether like some
subclasses of I know frauds or scratches
that were detected like easily or
naughty steel where there are any like
cases where it was really hard to to
find the difference so the test in this
case is very subjective so what we did
is we have ran the first time the model
then found something that the model
suggested like for example for every
image we found the top similar then we
put some threshold based on the cosine
similarity you can do it so clearly and
distance whatever and then expect
inspect usually some of the results to
understand what is going on once this
was done we created the test set inside
which we put the top examples and they
were containing three major four major
classes so one is the really the same
damage the other thing is something
which we called holistic which will
which looks really similar like it makes
you open the photo if you're even if
you're human and check really this is
same or not the third class was
something which we were calling [ __ ]
so it's something which is a bad result
and there are also symmetric images
because exception as every other model
train do an image that was invariant for
rotation flipping and so on although we
made it false in the model so these are
some we were quite sure that we need to
work on some of those areas like
scratches were very well detected even
in the rims of the wheel so
the surfaces which we didn't find quite
often in the data set as opposed to
maybe some deformation on the surface of
the Thunderer bumper where it gets a bit
harder especially with the shades and
the person standing next to the car
taking an image than the reflection of
the person in the image and so and the
second question was okay question thank
you for the presentation
can you show again how is the structure
of the network so is it like a Siamese
Network where you input both image at
the same time or how do you do it so
since we had a lot of brainstorming
about Siamese and triplets I'll try to
explain this very simple in one class of
the models you have out encoder which
works on one image then the second class
is a Siamese which is like picture one
picture to zero or one if it's the same
or not then this is like the third class
of the models which has as an input
picture one picture to picture three and
you know that picture too is always very
similar to picture one while picture
three is not it is for let's say human
but it's not for a fraud investigator so
this is where we try to differentiate so
the structure of the model this is the
model but every picture goes
independently in inside the neural
network and then what you work on is
actually the loss which you can see down
here defined so D is the distance and F
of query are the embeddings which were
extracted at this point so yeah I mean
the paper is published and reference
down in 2014 but back then they were
working with Alex not and some other
features of the model which we tweaked a
bit and changed thank you